Speaker 1: Republican Congressman Byron Donalds
appeared on Fox News and this was a disaster of
an interview. If I've ever seen one to the point
where even the Fox News host had to come in and
debunk everything he was saying about the Biden
documents versus Trump documents case. Of course,
now multiple locations, classified documents
have been found at Biden's properties or Biden
related properties, and that's being
investigated as it should. Obviously
much less severe than Trump's obstruction
and trying to purposely keep the documents
from the National Archives. And that's why
the raid was necessary. And we'll discuss
that further. But look at this moment where it
just does not go well and the Fox host can't
even save Byron Donalds from his own humiliation.
Speaker 5: Had no problem raiding Mar a Lago. But
let's go back even before the Mar a Lago raid.
Donald Trump's attorneys was in negotiations in
talks with the National Archives. They were well
aware of what was happening at Mar a Lago. So why
the FBI raid? You you you compare that to what's
happened with Joe Biden at his residence. Or, yes,
the FBI was there, but Merrick Garland didn't
do his job and making sure that they were
running the search and investigation to make sure
everything was found and secured. Third question
to Joe Biden's attorneys Do they have security
clearance to handle these documents and continue
that search? That's a major question as well.
Speaker 6: Yeah, well, we're going back to Mar
a Lago. Those negotiations had gone on for more
than a year between the Department of Justice,
the Trump Organization, and not the
Trump Organization, but the president's
post-presidential organization and the National
Archives and Records Administration. But at some
point, President Trump's attorneys told those
entities that all of the documents had been handed
over. When that wasn't the case, which is what
prompted the raid. So in terms of the differences
here, there do seem to be some. But you believe
that there is still a double standard here in
terms of how those two things were handled.
Speaker 5: Oh, absolutely. Without a doubt.
Because here's the other thing.
You get leaks to the press,
pictures of documents tossed all over the floor.
Speaker 1: So the thing just jumps to a completely
different thing. Okay, So. Even though both of
them stayed calm and talked professionally. That
was just so. I guess the word that keeps
going away is humiliating or embarrassing
because Byron Donalds is trying to go with
this new narrative from the right wing that,
listen, our concern is not about the classified
documents at the end of the day or I am concerned,
but that's not the main concern. The real
concern is the double standard. We cannot
have a two tiered justice system in the United
States, and nothing proves that we have that
more than the fact that Trump was raided and
Biden wasn't. And so we're going to discuss why
that so absurd. But let's kind of step back
for a second and walk through the timeline.
As we built up to this, the Trump Mar a Lago
situation was going on. The documents there,
a lot of the right wing Fox News Republicans
were just covering for Trump, defending him,
saying this was a witch hunt. Then the Biden
documents story breaks before any of the right
wing is able to get a read on how the left is
going to respond, how Democrats are going to
respond. They immediately say, see, nobody cares
when it's Biden. Everyone cares when it's Trump.
And then. Every single Democrat, minus
a few that I've seen. And as you know,
in a wholesale sense, I guess the left has
been very much okay with investigations into
Biden. And if there's wrongdoing, absolutely
hold the proper people accountable based on
the documents. We also make clear that there's
a big difference between the Trump and Biden
documents situation for sure. It's dishonest
to pretend that there's not, but there was. No,
don't talk about that. We'll talk about that as
they told us there would be. So then I watch is
kind of they had to work up a new talking point
to keep with the double standard before it was the
left's going to cover up by it and talk about
Trump. Then they realized nobody's trying to
cover up and not talk about Biden. So now it's the
double standard is Trump was rated. Biden was it?
But they never go one step further and try to
think about why that might be. Do you think
raids are necessary in every single investigation,
Outrage necessary every single time documents are
in the wrong place? No, the raid was necessary for
Trump because he obstructed. Time and time again,
the National Archives from getting the documents
they were requesting and requesting as the Fox
News host had to come in and say there. And
Trump knowingly lied and kept the documents,
which is why they had to eventually, after
being incredibly patient, raid Mar-A-Lago.
Biden immediately. Him and his team have complied,
have turned over the documents when they came
across them and are fully on board complying with
the investigation. Why would a raid be necessary?
Explain that to me. Why would a raid be necessary?
Genuinely? Very, very strange. Make sure you
are. Subscribe to The David Pakman Show YouTube
channel and I have a show of my own. Of course.
Down filling in for David while he is away. But
if you like what you're seeing, you go to Luke
Beazley on YouTube, link in the description on
YouTube and I'll see you after a quick break.